glitz glamour and six dollar iced
coffees
welcome to beautiful los angeles
california the entertainment capital of
the world
and home to the tiger belly seeing
competition we've received over 10
million submissions across 54 states
and nine different continents join us as
we embark on a journey
to find out which sleeper will sing the
tiger belly outro song
after carefully reviewing submissions
for months our submission committee
has chosen the top finalists at this
audition stage
of the competition your mentors bobby
and koloko
will choose their favorite songs and
those will move on throughout the
competition
so guys let's get started
[Applause]
[Music]